let's bring in senior political analyst
brit hume good evening brit
hi mike about a week after the final u.s
troops left afghanistan what's your
assessment of where things stand
well much as the body administration
would like to turn turn the page away
from this story
and focus on other things i don't think
the story will let them do that um
the media to some extent will comply and
and focus less on afghanistan than it
did so intensely there for several weeks
but the afghanistan is like a time bomb
over there i mean you've got the
situation has has been described at
mazari sharif you've got the possibility
that
there'll be a renewal of terror attacks
either on the u.s or its allies
emanating from afghanistan um and you
know you've got questions that are
undoubtedly going to be raised about a
couple of other things mike one of them
is you know how do we get all these
people out and not get all of our own
people out
that we needed to get out and and and
and who are these people that we did get
out were they properly vetted who are
they and of course if any of them turn
out to be you know actual terrorists
that will raise questions anew so i i
think we have a way to run on this story
mike whether the body administration
likes it or not for those of us who have
covered the white house over the years
senior officials serve at the pleasure
of the president
meaning you might be out of a job if
that's what the president needs do you
think brit some senior officials will be
ousted due to this messy withdrawal
well i think that the messy withdrawal
was largely on the shoulders of biden
himself everything that we've learned
about how the decisions were made come
down to biden said we wanted out we
wanted and the last
bastion we would have would be kabul in
the embassy uh that meant that bagram
had to be closed because he wouldn't uh
surge any more troops in so i think this
is overwhelmingly largely on biden but
you know
they can't fire him
and if this gets worse for him
politically he might feel the need to
get rid of some of these people and be
seen as starting you know turning over a
new leaf but so far he is stubbornly
clung
as peter ducey just reported to his
insistence that this whole thing was
real this this was a great success
i don't think the public agrees and i
don't think it's likely to start
agreeing anytime soon
brit with all these americans and some
afghan partners still stuck in the
country do you worry this could be worse
than the iran hostage crisis late in the
carter era
well some of the opportunities there for
the americans and others that are that
we care about
that are there to be taken as hostages
and used for bargaining i mean there's
some suggestion that might happen with
those that are trapped there at maseri
sharif
but i think that remains to be seen um
but it's certainly a possibility and
you know you've got in addition to
having the taliban in control there were
no friends of the united states you've
also got these terrorist elements there
uh al qaeda and
and isis uh k and uh
that may turn out to be uh willing to
grab people on the ground as well so
obviously it's a it's a worry it's part
of the ticking time bomb
britt we have a few seconds remaining
do you get a sense that president
biden's political advisers won out over
his national security advisers in this
case
well i think i'm not sure it was his
political advisers this joe biden is a
man who's throughout his long career
hasn't had a lot of fixed convictions
he's basically been a creature of the
democratic party in its current opinions
in this case however he developed a firm
conviction he didn't like this
afghanistan mission for a long time and
wanted out
um and i think so i don't think it was
his political advisors i think it was
him and
i think his military advisors were
indeed overruled
um apparently they haven't felt strong
enough so far to quit they're all still
there but uh but i think this is him
britt hume thanks so much for laboring
with us on this labor day many thanks
you bet you bet hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else